the director of Ted directs his second
live-action movie wanted to embed a
million ways to die in the West so a
million ways to die in the West is about
how it sucks in the West I pause when I
try to describe what this movies about
because I don't think this movie knows
what this movies about ultimately it
stars Seth MacFarlane he's his average
everyday schlub in the West and he's
like it sucks here that's a whole
monologue in the movie that you also
heard in the trailer where he's like
everything in the West is trying to kill
you every the medicine sucks everything
sucks that I want out of here so this
movie is ultimately about Seth
MacFarlane bitching about how the West
sucks and then he meets Charlize Theron
they kind of have a romance going on and
Liam Neeson tromped into town he's like
some one of the sounds gonna die I want
to kill Seth MacFarlane Seth MacFarlane
in this movie he's really had a place he
doesn't belong and that would be fine if
it didn't detract from the overall movie
here's what I mean by that Seth
MacFarlane in this movie [ __ ] so much
about how the West sucks that you're
like okay I get it you know it sucks
Kingdon all right let's just watch the
movie but then he keeps bitching about
how the West sucks every time something
happens he's like is another thing you
kill you in the West
oh this weather was sucks you know look
at that medicine and at a point you're
like dude you're a drag shut up
subtlety is really what makes humor if
you keep pushing something like this if
you keep pushing a [ __ ] attitude you
come across as some kid who's bitching
about the school he's in it's like yeah
we get it you hate it there we got that
like an hour ago branded the movie is
called a million ways to die in the West
so you know it's gonna be about that but
you can set that up with Seth MacFarlane
talking about it in one scene then after
that we will see everything that is
absurd about the West and then we can go
yeah that is crazy it's like we're not
idiots we'll get it Kirk just let the
movie go Seth MacFarlane's character or
this movie as a whole is like that
friend you don't really adore a friend
of a friend that you don't want to
invite to everything it's like all right
we're all gonna hang out uh does he work
tonight let's let's hang out what he
works
I don't know he's just a drag detracts
from the fun yeah the trailer showed a
lot of the funny parts in his movie but
that's really not the problem here the
problem is the movies just it's a mess
the movies about Seth MacFarlane's
character hating the West the movies
about Seth MacFarlane not being able to
shoot well so he has to shoot well
because he has to survive a duel the
movies about him trying to get his
friend Amanda Seyfried back from NPH
Neil Patrick Harris is like the best
thing in the movie every time he was on
screen I was like this new Solaris I
will say though there's a pretty
kick-ass bar fight in this movie what
rechoreograph that fight and made that
go down good job because that was hands
down the coolest part of the movie
sometimes when directors can do anything
they want the movie becomes their own
private joke that we're not really in on
they just make it because it amuses them
and it amuses nobody else yeah the movie
had some chuckles the movie did have a
couple laughs but nothing really made me
go to holy [ __ ] this is hilarious I
walked out of the movie going that was
boring so - the couple chuckles in this
movie a million ways to die in the West
was not that funny it was messy the
movie didn't know where it wanted to go
it had like four different plot points
all of which were individually just as
messy and sloppily stitched together as
the overall movie was as proof that just
because Ted was funny doesn't mean you
have to look forward to every Seth
MacFarlane thing out there there's a
million ways to die in the West I'm not
gonna remember it in t-minus one day yep
already forgot I'm gonna be honest with
you guys and trust me before I even get
started this baffles me a haunted house
- made me laugh more frequently and made
me laugh harder than a million ways to
die in the West I know that is fact
that's reality I'm done so let's talk
about disappointing comedies here what
was the most disappointing comedy for
you should have been funny completely
wasn't whatever it is comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more